à l'enterrement d'une feuille morte que
giscard go sans vent ils ont la coquille
noir du creps autour des cornes
ils s'en vont dans le noir un très beau
soir d'automne est là
quand ils arrivent c'est déjà le
printemps
l'héroïque étaient mortes sont toutes
ressuscité et les deux escargots sont
très désappointé mais voilà le soleil le
soleil qui leur dit prenez mais prenez
la peine la peine de vous asseoir prenez
un verre de bière si le coeur vous en
dit prenez il avoue play ledogar pour
paris il partira ce soir jeudi mais ne
prenez pas le deuil c'est moi qui ai
volts et savoir si le blanc de l'oeil
est cueilli
sans les 10 les histoires de ce recueil
c'est triste
lepage au lit vous prenez vos couleurs
des couleurs de la vie alors
toutes les bêtes les arbres et les
plantes se met à chanter à chanter à
tue-tête la vraie chanson vivante la
chanson de l'été et tout le monde de
boire tout le monde craque et se tape
très joli soir un jeu l'espoir était
et les deux escargots s'en retournent
chez eux ne s'en vont très ému il semble
très heureux comme ils ont beaucoup bu
et tu te bats un petit peu mais
dans le ciel